good morning all uh agent McMahon here
stay rep McMahon uh calling this meeting
to order and um this is the subcommittee
relative to House Bill 535 and with the
goal today uh is reviewing uh
information provided to us I want to
thank the parties that uh did some some
serious work on making some
recommendations for us to discuss so
thank you very much for responding from
our last meeting and making something
happen while we're
young uh to
consider and uh we'll be um moving
forward on this to see what
recommendations or what direction we
collectively come to
to consensus on and with the goal that
on the 31st of October is when the full
committee will be meeting to act on the
recommendations of the various uh on the
10 retained bills 535 being one uh on
recommendations to the to the house for
Action so that being being said I'll uh
we'll start our discussion right here
for our subcommittee members and um we
normally have six but uh two rep Gman
and rep zidel will not be in attendance
today so that I want everyone to know
that they wouldn't be coming in late U
the just the the ladies were not able to
make it today so uh that being said I'll
just we'll open this up to a discussion
for members and see what the thoughts
are based on information that was sent
out uh yesterday that we received and
and also there was um an get from Miss
Rosenberg and also from uh Miss sink uh
relative to recommendations to us and
did everyone received both of those on
their emails yes I want to make sure
that we're on on the same page and and I
was uh Happ to ask our support staff our
Authority having jurisdiction provided
the documents that are in front of you
that we uh to help us as
well so that being
said what uh let's start our discussion
what comments do do our members have
representative long thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank everybody for
their their work and and trying to
resolve this um so we we're looking at
two amendments
um I was wondering if we could speak to
um someone from each side uh to see
where they agree my understanding is
there are some issues of agreement and
where it stands out that there's not the
agreement and that's something that
we'll have to uh peel the onion on and
see where where we slide with that so I
I don't know if uh uh Miss s uh if you
could come up to explain your well
actually it be the chairman to call you
up uh and and somebody else from uh the
other
negotiators it's up to CH well yeah we
want Cooperative collaboration so both
of you come up okay if you
would do we need another seat need
another seat
there we can have people on deck if
needed me
too good afternoon um thank you for the
opportunity to be here today and thank
you for the work that you're doing on
this um I guess i' I'd like to St start
by saying that um I'm Marsha sink excuse
me CEO of kaso New Hampshire um that
it's been it's been a lot of good work
that we've gotten done over the past
several weeks um at your at your
suggestion um chairman McMahon and um we
came to consensus on many things um but
there were a few obstacles that got in
the way of us being in complete um
completely on board with each other
other's ideas uh suggestions and
recommendations for the change to the
statute so um I just wanted to start by
saying that that um I think there are
people that put in a tremendous amount
of work I know there were people that
put in a tremendous amount of work um I
think the challenge for us was the
actual implementation of what some of
what has been um uh suggested by uh by
the folks um under the um just G R Jr BG
um group sorry um and I just know them
by their first names primarily so um but
that just without the Court's
involvement in this process more more um
heavily involved and that of
DCF um that those are the folks that are
really going to be the ones in charge of
of making all of this happen for our
kids and the courts so that's when we I
think in the end decided that we
couldn't be in agreement with everything
and we wanted to go back to what we had
offered last uh last session was just
that minimal change to uh the child
protection statute that opens the
opportunity for discre the discretion of
the court to appoint an attorney at any
stage of the proceedings the way it
currently reads now is we are um we are
limited to when that request can be made
and um it's typically made by the
guardian at lium this offers the
opportunity for any party um to request
it and at any point in those proceedings
so that a child who um maybe at the
dispositional phase it was didn't think
we needed an attorney but further on in
the proceedings at a review hearing or
um you know if the child was in
residential placement and things like
that and it was extending in time that
the request for an attorney technically
could not be made although some of our
judges have felt it was critically
important that they do um that they do
make that appointment at a different
point in the hearing uh this allows
allows them the opportunity again it
just broadens that and that so we went
back to that original language because
we couldn't come to full agreement on
some of the other pieces I guess is the
fair way to present it um but um before
having just a clarification Miss sink
and appreciate you sending out the email
this morning yes comment that uh struck
out with me I wanted to just get your
guidance for all of us here where um it
stated in on the in the email that DCF
and the Judiciary were not part of the
discussions regarding the proposed
language that now that being said is
there not inherent conflict then on what
would be recommended as it goes through
the quote process that if they weren't
given if I mean that those two entities
weren't given the voice as part of this
that we there would be a challenge in
having it
supported go ahead it's our
understanding that the Judiciary does
not weigh in on policy uh but that we
thought it was important from an
administrative standpoint not necessar
and the division we know often does not
take a position on certain legislation
but the we do think it's critically
important for both the Judiciary and DCF
to at least talk us through how this
would work administ atively um I think
on the specifically with the legislation
that's one of the sticking points was
children who are at risk of being placed
in a residential facility so if you look
at the proposal um the amendment to 169
c102b and uh chairman mcmah you asked
where did or representative long where
did the parties agree I think we came to
a point where we could agree that
children who are currently in a
residential
facility should be appointed Council the
problem was the rest of that paragraph
Was how do we
determine children who the division may
need to place and that was really the
more we looked at this language the more
complicated it became and this is the
kind of language we think specifically
that the Judiciary and
DCF talk us through to when the division
suspects they need to place a child in a
facility what does that look like how
could that look like how quickly could
the Judiciary respond to this so to
answer your question no they can't weigh
in on a yay or nay but to let the
parties better understand how the people
who will actually have to implement this
law daytoday how this is going to work
and so we think that their voices were
um were critical so that that in
particular
that whole language after
um that starts except in the case of an
emergency and there was agreement on um
from the other side that if the
division I'm I'm actually looking at the
the language that um Karen Rosenberg
submitted I've
got is that 2B yeah oh 2B okay right
here
yeah
so everything starting with accept and
everything down we thought was clunky
and unclear and difficult to
administer and frankly it's our position
it's kasa's position we don't have the
resources to support this I mean that's
a I mean po I know this is a policy
organization but this language assumes
we have F other Foster families we've
got other resident other relative
placements and we have attorneys I mean
that that's remained a concern that
right now we do not have a system in
place to support this legislation we
wish we did we really wish we did um
it's our concern that if if legislation
is enacted without a system to support
that children um that this will not be
good for
kids representative thank you chairman I
just have one question because I want to
understand you guys and by the way thank
you all for being here when I think
about you know who's protecting the
children in our um communities you guys
are all the Heavy Hitters so thank you
very much for everything that you do um
so when I look at this and I hear you
that the resources and stuff I want to
understand more like of that groundwork
whenever you have a case where a kiddo
is you find out that there they might be
placed or that this is going to happen
what does that time period look like
because I'm seeing like two days and
stuff like I I know I have friends in
other areas that are foster parents and
it comes up very quick like within an
hour so what what does that timeline
what would language like that this do
with that timeline and that's I think
that's exactly the concern is we haven't
defined what an emergency is is an
emergency that the child is setting
fires in the foster home that the child
has killed the Foster family's pet I
mean what an emergency look like in our
cases is very it depends on the child
depends on the home and that we think
that the division does need to respond
pretty quickly and depending on where
the child can go it it depends the
challenge with looking at the children
at risk or children who the division is
contemplating it's more subtle than that
it's the family is not accepting of a of
the child's sexual orientation or the CH
the the child is allergic to the family
pet you know the situation where we know
it's not a good fit but and we know the
child needs to be removed but gosh we
don't have a place to put this child we
don't have another foster home so we
feel the division needs to be able to
have its statutory authority to be the
child's custodian to temporarily place a
child in a situation to prevent the
escalation and disregulation that could
occur that could not be harmful of the
child to leave that child in a situation
that is not in the child's best interest
and I think to add to that this was
really intended for children who are at
risk of placement in a residential
facility so it's not necessarily just
about Foster moving from one foster home
to another but it was being able to
identify those those kids at risk of
being placed in a residential
facility thank you so in a residential
like what does that I know that it's
each case is individual but what does
that typically look like as far as
what's your time frame from the time
when you find out like I'm just I just
want to be very um pragmatic about you
know it if you add resources like what
would this bottleneck things what in
your opinion would it and I wouldn't
mind you guys answering as well that
would be great but I just want to
understand and not complicate the
timeline from when this thing need to
happen um for the record I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center and I'm a
member of what's known as the juvenile
rights policy group and that consists of
New Hampshire legal assistance Waypoint
new Futures the children's Law Center of
New Hampshire the ACLU of New Hampshire
um and wait who would I
forget got it all um so six
organizations who all stand behind the
amendment that I emailed to the
committee
yesterday um and in in part I want to
just remind you that at the last
Committee hearing the work session um
this members of this committee expressed
a desire to not do this halfway um there
were big concerns about children who had
been placed at
bledo a really dangerous facility and
those children were not represented by
Council and um and although you know it
is one thing we all agree on here is the
importance of kasas and how valuable
their role is in these proceedings
because they form really good
relationships with children they have
you know they are talking to DCF they're
talking with um the parents um but um
but they're not attorneys they have
attorneys but they are not attorneys and
it can be very difficult for a volunteer
Casa to secure records at a at an away
facility to have contact with their
children when they're far away and
having a child's appointed counsel can
make a big difference in terms of
cutting through a lot of bureaucracy and
asserting the child's rights under the
law so I think that one of the things
that this committee directed us to do
was to look beyond the Court's
discretionary authority to appoint
councel and see if there was a way to
come together with all of our
organizations and decide and come up
with some language that would address
the risks and real harm that children
may suffer when they are
unnecessarily placed at residential
facilities and so that is what we
attempted to
do now I it should be noted that the
courts were actually invited to our we
met twice in person following the
committee's meeting and the courts were
invited to participate in both of those
meetings um Aon mcran did or krian did
participate in one meeting and was I
think unavailable for our second meeting
however she informed us really clearly
that the court was not able to take a
position or not going to take a position
on an amendment she provided some
information to us that was really
helpful in um you know in terms of how
they would respond to legislation that
might come out so it was helpful to have
her there we did not invite DF to the
table in part because we been informed
by their Council in the past that they
are not taking a position on whether
children ought to have Council appointed
in abuse and neglect proceedings um and
for reasons that you discussed it would
be very it might be challenging it was
already challenging we worked really
hard to try to get to yes with all of
our
organizations and um that would add
another wrinkle however we did look at
DS dcyf policy um about how placement
decisions are made and what their
procedures are there are people on the
Jr RPG not myself but um Lisa Wolford
and Michelle werin who represent
children in these situations who drew
from their own experience so we did have
and and of course Casa also has a lot of
experience dealing with um individuals
and children in these situations so um
we really don't think that the fact that
dcwf was not at the table is really a
barrier to this committee making an
informed decision about how to proceed
so um that aside um there the object
here was to broaden the Court's
discretion um which I think we did
pretty much pretty easily um agree on
language that would broaden the Court's
discretion to appoint
counsel um and I think that you know
when we spoke about it as um as Caroline
me Delaney mentioned to you we did agree
and that it was pretty easy to say if
kids are in residential facilities they
ought have Council appointed we agreed
in principle on the idea that when
children are at imminent risk not you
know not a you know not just a thought
of risk but that there was definitely a
real risk that they might be placed in a
residential um facility that they ought
to have Council appointed and so we did
our best to Define what that was and in
doing that um what we did was we looked
at dcf's current policy on when they you
know what the procedures are when they
think that it's possible that a child's
needs cannot be met um in a foster
family or kinship home or in their
parents home and a residential placement
should be considered and what DCF policy
says is that they should refer the child
for an independent assessment where
they're using is the cans so we use that
as a as one touch point for when uh
because they're they are knowing that
they're going to be referring the child
for an assessment and the purpose of
that assessment is to make a
determination does the child need to be
placed in a residential facility and and
part of that decision goes to what the
child's you know emotional mental health
needs are as well as to whether you know
whether those needs could be met in the
community so we thought that was a touch
point that we could agree upon when DCF
decides that they are going to be
referring someone that they would notify
the court of that fact so then the court
could go and appoint
counsel it didn't the other thing that
our group felt was important was to also
consider when as a touch point when DCF
sends packets to facilities because what
we've learned in our experience with
children is that oftentimes DCF doesn't
follow the policy of on of not sort of
holding back on a referral um to a
residential
placement um until they've our
perspective and considering when Council
ought to be appointed for
children we've considered that children
are also at risk not just when DCF is
considering doing this cans assessment
but also if DCF is actively referring
children for consideration for admission
to a facility so that appears in this
amendment and and the and what would
happen on in this amendment that we're
asking you to consider is that at that
point DCF would notify the court um that
they are pursuing possible placement
either through the assessment or through
referring children by sending their
individual information to facilities and
then it would be up to the court to
appoint counsel there's nothing in here
that says that the placement is held up
however and and we understand that it
could take time time while we are
developing attorneys to represent
children and training them and making
sure they're prepared there might be
delays that's but we're setting up a
statute that is going to be not for just
today not just for tomorrow but for into
the future for how children's rights and
their best interests are going to be
protected and it's a little bit of a
chicken and egg situation if we don't do
anything to guarantee a right for
representation for children that their
most vulnerable stage when they are at
the highest risk of being ripped out of
their schools ripped out of their
communities removed from their homes and
put in an institution if we don't get
that into law then we're never going to
develop that pool of attorneys because
they they won't be required right if we
require them then we're going to develop
that pool of attorneys to represent
children in emergency
situations which we did not Define
purposely to allow for some
flexibility a child can be removed a
child can be removed from a dangerous
situation and the court wouldn't get
notice of the child's removal even
removal to a facility a residential
facility they would after the child is
removed from that facility would be when
DCF would notify the court and then at
that point the court would appoint
counsel for the child but there was no
intention to leave children lingering in
a dangerous situation all that we
intended to do here was set up a
framework for when DCF would notify the
court that either the child is placed or
at really high risk of being placed in a
facility and then it would be up to the
court to appoint counsel for that
child another thing that we thought was
really important that's also in this
amendment is that with regard to those
discretionary appointments where a child
might with this expanded discretion be
able to ask the court to appoint counsel
for something other than a placement a
residential you know a facility
placement because that's another right
that would the child would have and
there is a foster care children's Bill
of Rights we felt it was really
important that the foster care
children's Bill of Rights be amended to
reflect that additional right that a
child would have to simply request
appointment of counsel it's not again
guarantee that they would get counsel
but at least they would be informed as
they are informed about a whole lot of
other rights like the right to have Team
meetings and participate in team
meetings right to normaly all the things
that are in the Foster children's Bill
of Rights we felt it was really
important that children be notified when
they're that the the rights have been
expanded in some way um and that also
turned out to be a bit of a sticking
point um I think because of a
misunderstanding that our organizations
had about the import of that so
I I don't know if that I mean that's a
long-winded response and probably didn't
even answer your question but I'm I'm
hoping it was
helpful was it helpful representative
Greg so how could that not be helpful um
it was I'm not even sure that my
question um needs to be answered at that
point now because I'm reading that and
kind of understanding but yeah thank you
for that it was all helpful all the
information by the way I mean we sit on
a committee where half of us agree
sometimes and half of us don't so we
certainly understand how disagreements
can happen with the best of intentions
so um yeah I don't have any further
questions right now I'm still like
absorbing all
that if we could just take a moment to
respond kaso I mean again attorney
Rosenberg and I were up until the end of
the day on Monday we've been talking a
lot on this with respect to the adding
to the children's Bill of Rights that
was something um that that Casa had
agreed to but what did not make the
proposal and that the reason why we
couldn't fully get behind it was an
issue that we brought up at the last
hearing we wanted inclusion in the
amendment that children and their
attorneys cannot participate in the
adjudicatory hearing and we had raised
our concerns about this at the last
hearing that children that that parents
could try to manipulate their children
that a child would be faced potentially
with being either feeling they need to
lie on their on the stand or forever
feeling guilty that it was their fault
that the division got involved with
their family and children do feel guilty
about that that if I hadn't spoken up
that maybe you know that DCF wouldn't be
involved with my family and so it's
kasa's position that the parents that
the children should not be involved in
that initial Hearing in terms of
contesting whether or not they are an
abused or neglected child under the law
and one other point that I believe that
there may be a misconception that every
other party in these cases has an
attorney and that's that's not entirely
accurate it is only with respect to
right to counsel it is only a parent who
is the petitioned parent has a right an
Indigent to be appointed an attorney so
in the case of a father who has never
been involved in the child's life or
minimally involved in the child's life
and is not not the petition parent
meaning he is not the parent who is
responsible for the abuse neglect he is
does not get appointed an attorney if he
is not a household member and I
respectfully think that's something the
committee should look at in terms of
every parent having an attorney in these
cases we also have women who are victims
of domestic violence who if they are not
the party responsible and the and they
are not a household member father has
been removed she in some cases is not
appointed an attorney even if we have
filed Casa a motion saying listen it's
in the child's best interest if Mom can
come to the hearing and talk about how
the kids are doing and she's told the
court I'm too afraid of my abuser and
I'm not going to open my mouth so we
think everybody in a it would be great
if everybody had representation and
everybody's rights are being protected
we just think there's a whole lot here
um
and that a good first step would be to
allow those kids both in residential
both who are um where the case really
warrants it to have judges have the
ability to point law lawyers now for
those kids and then we are ready willing
and able to continue to have late night
conversations and to keep going back and
forth and hopefully find something that
will um that will work best for New
Hampshire's
children repres resentative
long thank you Mr chairman so I mean I'm
of the opinion and I'm not in the trenes
as you all are uh but I'm of the opinion
that the judicatory hearing is one of
the best um you know has the potential
of driving this child to where their
future's going to be uh at that decision
um so I I wonder why you sense that an
attorney should not be represented a
child I'm not talking about a parents
I'm just in regard to to the child and
I'm not talking about the child being
there I'm talking about the attorney
representing the child at these
proceedings why would that be
harmful in many Cas in some cases it
might not be it raises If the child is
represented at the adjudicatory hearing
we do think and this happens where
parents attorneys try to subpoena
children to testify and that where
parents will say my child is lying my
child is
exaggerating about the the abuse and
it's the worst cases it's the sexual
abuse cases it's the worst physical
abuse cases if we do have a concern that
even if the attorney is there that um
that children that parents will try well
that you can protect the child in the
adjudicatory hearing because the
attorney will be able to jump up and
object I mean right now there isn't
there isn't a proposal to keep children
from coming to that hearing and I will
also say that RSA one uh 169 c18 the
adjudicatory hearing statute only
addresses petitioners typically the
state and petition the parents so there
isn't anything currently in the
adjudication statute that all that even
suggests including Casa I mean the
guardian ad lium also in in that statute
is not included as a party that presents
evidence or cross-examines Witnesses so
that statute needs to get changed as
well if there's any suggestion that CH
children attorneys are going to take an
active part at the adjudicatory hearing
so if one of the parties is looking to
subpoena the child does that happen even
if though there's an attorney not there
I would think yes it CIF files a motion
to quash we we file and and we're we
we're successful saying it is not
appropriate for the child to be uh
subpoena to testify at the adjudicatory
hearing uh there is um there's New
Hampshire Supreme Court case in Ray G
that talks about the policy reasons
behind why we keep kids from um hearing
I mean even though that they're the
victims to needing to be a part
of litigating
this I'd like to interject um first of
all I think that um when you look at the
adjudicatory hearing one of the things
that is an issue is family
Integrity that is a very important right
and one that the child has a real
interest in and a lot of children are
not going to want to have anything to do
with these adjudicatory hearings but if
they happen to be appointed councel and
they want their councel to weigh in on
that you know basically dissolution of
their family potentially um that seems
very appropriate and that if you
appointed Council it would be a
violation of the tri it would be it
would make it impossible for Council to
actually do their jobs if they were
prohibited or presented with barriers
that other Council don't have in
hearings secondly that the case that um
was raised enry GG 166 New Hampshire 193
basically in that Supreme Court case a
father did try to subpena his child um
and the and the Supreme Court and and
the and the trial court said no you
can't you're not going to be a to Su
subpoena the child we're not going to
have the kid here there was a video
testimony and that's good enough the
Supreme Court ended up taking that case
and basically said it was appropriate
for the court not to require that child
to testify that the that 169c is about
in in large part determinations about
what's in the best interest of the child
and then the court went on to talk about
factors that the court that courts ought
to consider in determining whether
children ought to be brought in to
hearings and that would include things
like um factors would include the
specific potential harm to the child if
they were required to testify whether or
not there are alternatives to the um to
inquir testimony that would meaningfully
that would provide the information that
the other party is trying to elicit and
nowhere does this decision say that
children should not participate in any
portion of the decision courts have
discretion and it's it's in the court
protocols they have discretion to
determine whether a child ought to be
able to participate in any one of these
proceedings including the adjudicatory
proceeding there are federal funds that
are available not a lot so don't start
spending them too quickly but if we
wanted to um take advantage of them for
E funds um which are federal funds are
available to defay the cost of
representation and what all the policy
and rules say um about the
implementation of 4 funds and using them
for this purpose is that those funds are
available at all stages of the
proceeding it does not ex say that you
know if the children cannot participate
or have attorneys to participate in
these
hearings so it would really of of the 38
or so states that have um fully
established rights to counsel for
children none of them say that the child
cannot have counsel at a judicatory
hearings so you know if we we were to
adopt a policy like that New Hampshire
would be an outlier um like I said I
don't know that this would come up very
often but to hamstring an attorney
prevent an attorney from doing you know
what they would be required to do under
rules of professional conduct when they
have a client the child I think would
really be a disservice to everyone okay
follow I if I may uh in your experiences
have you seen where uh judge uh Woulda a
child and have the child speak or is
that rare or
none I only um thus far I've had one
case it was a physical assault case
where a mom allegedly broke her
teenager's jaw and the mom wanted like a
criminal case to was alleging uh
self-defense and it was before the
statute was changed we were successful
in keeping the child from being required
to testify at the family court proceding
proing at that time there was um we had
denovo appeals to the superior court and
the superior court judge allowed um
denied I had filed a motion in lemon
that uh to prevent the child from being
required to testify and in that case and
personally I think it's because Superior
Court judges weren't accustomed to
seeing uh a lot of family cases and also
see more criminal cases um but that we
we have had one case where that was
required the child so I'm I'm I'm
looking to get a clear indication as to
why it's
problematic uh with an attorney in the
adjudicatory hearing uh one of them was
uh with respect to subing the child I
mean if the child if for the for the
attorney to be there I mean for example
Casas do not participate guard and
private Guardian Adlabs do not
participate in the adjudicatory hearing
they are not referenced as participants
in the adjudicator hearing statute are
they they they of course they are
present they're present at the
preliminary hearing and they're present
to certainly hear all that information
and we are not saying that children's
attorneys if they've been appointed an
attorney should not be present but
should not um participate in the
adjudicatory hearing okay and and uh if
I may ask M Rosenberg a question
uh having having having the attorney
present in my opinion would give the
attorney the you know the upper hand to
know what's going on so that he could
immediately represent the child knowing
what the discussion was all
about where where what's what's
important to you where the attorney has
to be part of the
uh what if the evidence does not
indicate that there actually was abuse
or neglect that it's not pro that really
let's say
poverty and the child wasn't connected
the family wasn't really connected with
the kind of resources that were
necessary so that the child could have
adequate nutrition or what if it was
some you know something else is going on
the attorney's participation could be
critical in deter in the Court's
ultimate determination about whether
this should be the complaint should be
petition should be founded or whether
there ought to be other services looked
at or put into place rather than a
founded petition which could you know
these decisions have a effect okay so I
think you know it off the fly it's hard
I me I think some of my colleagues might
be able to come up with some other
examples of where having an attorney
would be really could be important to
children like I say I don't think it
will come up very often but to basically
prohibit this upfront instead of relying
on the law that currently exists that
gives courts discretion about whether
children participate in any of these
proceedings or whether their Council
participate um um we don't need to touch
that with this amendment okay so so the
intent of what I'm hearing is there's
another statute that would have to be
change because the intent is with the
petitioner uh with the two parties uh
which of course the children are brought
up uh so that's where I'm trying to
define the importance of the attorney
being there I I lean towards yes um it's
important if if this attorney is going
to represent that child um going for
forward that in every aspect they should
be there uh I'm I'm in the middle of
just being there uh allowing allowing an
appointment of an attorney to uh be
present uh you know at minimum yeah I if
if I could respond to two things um I
think the cases that we see and as you
know we see hundreds of these cases and
we're involved in hundreds of these
cases it's very infrequent that the what
when a child is removed or when a
petition is filed that it is for things
like neglect night um not being fed well
or poverty dcyf H investigates
investigates and investigates and
reports are made and reports were made
if if anything we see the reverse of
that we see petitions being filed that
should have been filed much sooner and
it's very rare that it is just that a
family is in need of services because
there are other referral opportunities
and there's a lot of work being done and
Statewide in the whole prevention Arena
so the kids never even show up in court
and the families get what they need in
advance because it is a horrible
experience for everyone
involved one of the things that could
potentially happen and I'm not an
attorney so these kind speak to this
better um but I think if if the attorney
at the judicatory hearing is
representing what their client wants
their expressed issues and if that
12-year-old little girl who's been
sexually abused repeatedly by mom's
boyfriend's stepdad says I want to go
home I really want to go home it's up to
her attorney then if they're at that
adjudicatory hearing to say my my client
wants to be returned home it's clearly
not in her best interest to be returned
home cuz Mom can't keep her safe or for
whatever reasons but he needs to argue
that point to the court if he is truly
advocating for what his client wishes
and I think that's one of the
complicating figures things that could
get factored into the adjudicatory
hearing I mean we have had so many cases
where kids do want to be returned but it
isn't safe and if that attorney is
representing what their client wishes
which is what their role is that that
gets it's messy and it gets it puts kids
at risk of being returned to unsafe
homes so I okay okay that if so no so so
would would you be okay with an
appointment of an attorney prior to the
adjudicatory however they could they
wouldn't participate but they would be
present I that's that's not an issue I
don't think so I don't think so no she
she no we don't think so hang on Karen
geez okay okay thanks
thanks I know I'm a lot um I I mean I
think there's a big difference in being
at a hearing and having your hands tied
and not being able to represent your
clients interests and just because a
child has an attorney appointed who
represents their CH their clients
expressed interest doesn't mean that the
attorney's going to win right we know
that there's basically it's just going
to raise the level of the discussion and
what's what the court considers so the
court will hear from the casa who will
present all the facts I'm sorry they
hear from D they'll hear from DCF excuse
me I stand corrected thank you um who
will hear the petition and all the facts
that they're relying on they'll hear
from the parent and they'll hear from
the child's attorney and the court will
make a decision having heard all of the
arguments and it as Marty discussed
where there are you know very detailed
investigations where decisions maybe
should have been made long time ago and
there's multiple incidents the courts
will hear that and when the attorney if
the attorney happens to be appointed
because the child was placed
residentially and the child says I
really want to go home the attorney will
engage in a discussion with their client
the attorney will say here's what the if
if they're doing their job they'll say
here's what the evidence shows I'm
really sorry but the evidence shows that
you've been victimized 20 times over the
last year and you sexually assaulted and
all these terrible things and that all
of the interventions that were done on a
voluntary basis didn't work and so the
court probably isn't going to say you
can go home but let's talk about what
you're you know what's what what else is
going on here may maybe there's some
other Solutions and so maybe what the
attorney would do is look at did DCF due
due diligence in looking for kinship
placements as an alternative to a
facility because we're only talking
about children now who are in facilities
did they did DCF um really exhaust
Foster families as an as a potential
Source did you know did is the facility
that you're placed at even appropriate
is there another facility that's closer
are these things that you might consider
and and they might be able to actually
talk to their client and get Authority
from their client to express the
client's desire to return home but maybe
with some interim steps so it's it's not
black and white but what this does is it
prevent it presents an opportunity for
the child to feel respected that their
opinion is respected that they are that
what they say matters and what they care
about matters to have it fully
considered by the court because if their
attorney is there you know even if the
attorney tries to get the you know talks
to their client about what they think
you know might be reasonable or that the
court might order in Le of you know
instead of bringing them home and and
they make the argument and the court
doesn't do that the child is heard the
child is empowered in this situation
where they've been completely out of
control where their world is upside down
where really even though they're their
abusers their parents are the only
parents that have been their parents at
least they've been heard and can be
empowered by this but if their attorney
has to just sit still idly it's okay I'm
glad I'm not the only one we're both
grabby people I'm I'm worse than she is
all right I admit I'm worse than you
Marty
um if if you know that that at least the
child would be heard and the judge will
make a decision about what needs to
happen BEC and and like I said attorneys
don't always win see but I'm thinking of
the potential of conflict with the child
and their new attorney also if if I I
mean I don't believe again I'm not your
the experts as you
are but I know there have there have
been abused and neglected children that
want to be with
their parent it's their parent they know
you know yeah so so I I get that right
and for an attorney who's who's the
child's being told that they're going to
represent your expressed uh wants what
what is it that you want and I say I
want to go with my mother uh and he
explains to me well you know your mother
hasn't done a good job so far uh you
know in a nice manner um you know that
may
diffuse the child feeling that this
person is representing me and we want
and we want the child to feel like
they're empowered okay I have somebody
who has my best interest you know so I
don't I don't know right from the get-go
if I tell I want to be my mother and
they explained to me that it's not a
good idea that I would be like wait a
minute I you know yeah I yeah if I if we
could just back up again we were in
complete agreement ment about a
a children who are placed in residential
facilities should have counsel period
the end we're in we're in agreement with
that where where we got stuck was that
that appointment happened at
adjudication so if I mean there's a lot
of consensus but that was one of the
points because P to representative long
because that could potentially
complicate things for the child but that
attorney representation if their in
placement is abs absolutely we support
that we think it's important and so that
those and primarily it's youth that are
placed in residential facilities that
they have that they have a voice in that
proceeding that they have an attorney
standing by their side they also will
have a casa standing by their side or
another G so um but I think that was
that was one of the sticking points was
that when the appointment of that
Council occur of council occurred right
so so in my mind I'm thinking not
necessarily when uh but participant or
present I mean as far as the
adjudicatory present is okay your issue
was uh um
participating and we actually have
language that we could forward that was
an amendment to 169 c18 that
specifically stated that the if if an
attorney is appointed pursuant to uh C10
that they would not participate at the
adjudicatory hearing that was language
we asked to be um included just for for
this issue and we understand reasonable
Minds disagree all the time uh but this
language did not make it into a a final
consensus draft but if that is important
to to the representative we could
forward that
okay anything
further from the individual to your
right Madam s thank thank you so much uh
Lisa Wolford for the children's Law
Center of New Hampshire I I um they've
covered a lot and so I I don't want to
retread old ground but but I will say
because the statute now the child
protection act does not um does not
weigh in on when
Council on whether Council or the child
should be present at the adjudicatory
hearing I I I don't think that's
something um that you should be
concerned about I I think it is best to
leave theate statute as is and and as is
is that the statute does not address uh
who should be at the adjudicatory
hearing and who should not it is it is
accurate that 169c
183 talks about uh the matter being
adjudicated so whether the parent is
neglectful or abusive and refers to the
state and the parents uh and the parents
um so if a child's lawyer came to an
adjudicatory hearing because their child
wanted them to be their client wanted
them to be there and their client wanted
them to participate in the hearing the
the attorney presumably would let the
judge know that that was their intention
they they they can't just uh barge over
to the witness um uh you know they they
can't just start calling Witnesses right
so I I think that this is a ter a
determination that our judges are
equipped to make uh and I think in the
first instance we should leave it to
judges to make those determinations
I mean we we we I I don't recall the
amendment that
um yesterday so yesterday apparently we
talked about it yesterday but that flew
over my head that that is something that
that I I don't think makes sense and and
um and would not a agree to to to if I
understand it correctly and it's not
before you it has not been uh proposed
to you but as I understand it correctly
what attorney delini was saying is that
the The Proposal was an amendment to uh
c183 that would exclude um the child and
their councel from the adjudicatory
proceedings which we think for the
reasons that you you've you've discussed
representative long um and attorney
Rosenberg have address are not
appropriate because we do think children
when they decide that they want to be
there which is not going to be every
case and so we're talking about a
limited number of cases right and
limited number of kids who want to
participate but when they decide they
want to be there
um they should be empowered uh with that
presence a a at the time when uh a
fundamental decision which will
profoundly alter their lives is going to
be made right and if I could just uh
give one more followup question on that
uh do you suspect that there will be
more children knowing that they have an
attorney that would want to go to the
judicatory hearing and that would be a
concern of mine I I'm thinking I'm 12
years old I got an attorney I'm
stretching my sister Benders and uh yes
I want you there and uh by the way I'd
like to be there myself um so I I so but
you're saying that
that won't necessarily be the case
there's no there's no guarantee I I
think that's right there there isn't I
mean I have clients who don't want to
come to court and and their causas and
um their caas beg them to come to court
DCF wants them to come to court the
judge wants them to come to court they
don't want to go to court okay um I I
have clients who do want to come to
court and I I file motions to ensure
that they're transported um so but I
think the difference at the adjudication
is that's where their parent I mean it's
like a trial right that's where their
parents and and for them to potentially
witness that yeah I I don't I think that
can add just another trauma to the
traumas that they've already experienced
so I I guess
that's why we struggle with this
appointment at adjudication because if
if the attorney if the if the child who
is like a client of the attorney wants
to attend the client really has
has to do what their client is directing
them to do so but the judge doesn't
right and so so
inry happy to give you my one copy which
is in my binder but in regg makes very
clear it is up to the judge whether the
child testifies and and presumably the
judge could also decide and maybe
there's a legal argument about the
child's rights whether the child has do
process rights to attend versus the
judge's determination of their best
interest but in Reg
in that case that child dcyf represented
to the to the uh Family Division or the
tri might have been a superior court
case but represented to the trial judge
that the the child's therapist would
provide testimony that the child should
not be present in court and should not
testify um and the Supreme Court said
that is great judges should make those
determinations and take all of that
information into
consideration agreed if given the
opportunity right well the judge will
always have the opportunity I I yeah I
understand that I think if a child
doesn't NE a child could be present but
not necessarily be required to testify
and just being present in the courtroom
could be traumatic for the child but the
judge could make a determination about
presence understand so am I witnessing
how your conversations with these last
couple couple of weeks it's complicated
it's very complicated and you wanted
something simple I believe
representative
long but but I'm I'm still not sure why
I well I I get that I guess that that's
what Kasa wants I mean I think the the
agreement is that CH more children
should have lawyers um children who are
in placement should have lawyers and
then children we believe who are at risk
of placement risk being defined the way
we've proposed um which we think is
clear which relies on the language of
dcyf policy
1615 um those kids should have counsel
the the issue about the adjudicatory
hearing is one that every judge in every
case can
decide and at risk of placement means
residential placement just so we're
clear
right anything further from from
Members thank you Mr
chairman
um
yeah I wanted to I wanted to
clarify I got a little more uh
clarification on on the RIS of placement
of of um residential
placement uh so that that's clear there
so it's residential placement uh with
respect to cans what what you know when
when we when when a child um an
emergency is placed in a residential
placement and they are going to do the
cans uh assessment um what what is that
time frame because is that sort of a
child in limbo or or what is what is the
time frame of this assessment when when
would the when would the courts get a um
get an
assessment you may approach the bench
Miss mford yes yeah just get comfortable
there will you okay thank
you
okay uh and and in anybody's
experience has that been problematic uh
I'm sure it has been a few times
but percentage wise is there is there a
lot of
um uh there was a lot of added trauma to
children when they're waiting for 30
days in a placement and then maybe some
of the assessments say you know what I
think we have a
foster uh family that would be able to
take this child because my understanding
is those can assessments that they do
levels okay and my understanding is uh
some of these placements when you give a
level um it's a turnoff yeah no we're
all set we we we're not interested
um so so I'm wondering if uh um I'm I'm
wondering if uh after an
assessment has there been
reconsideration
for whether a foster home or
um you know a family member
or do do you
know
and the cat it's the cat assessment the
Maximus cat um not the cans which is a
different assessment uh but where the
where the cans concludes that the child
does not need to be removed in in uh and
put in placement in my experience um the
kid was not removed so they the DCF was
waiting for the for the cat assessment
result before moving the kid I I mean DF
should would be referring kids for cat
assessments if they believe that the the
child's needs indicate residential
placement and that should be done prior
to a child moving um I think probably
and and maybe maybe others will have
other information but the times during
which the cat is done after placement
are those emergency placements okay yeah
I'm I'm just trying to get my arms
around the emergency placements that's
seems a little problematic so so I I
agree with with attorney Rosenberg that
that
emergency means what its common
dictionary definition is and and that
DCF should know what that means the
party should know and a judge should
know there's nothing in the language
that we've proposed that would inhibit
DCF from placing a child um based on
their perception of what an emergency is
I mean once Council for a child is
appointed um the attorney might take
issue with the the uh emergency
assessment and I I suppose that could be
litigated but but dcyf could move the
child um and they do move children based
on a conclusion about emergency
emergency in my experience means the kid
has to move right period all right very
good thank you thank
you
would anyone have any further
comments from the attendees
here oh you can get get up right right
with her if you'd
like it just confirms that you will be
heard good afternoon for the record
Cassandra Sanchez child advocate for the
State of New
Hampshire um and as others um May had
mentioned prior um my office had been
involved in meetings discussing the
Amendments that are before you today um
we have been in agreement with the
assessment that was put forth by the
jrpg um in which um this is the one with
the more extensive language um in which
children in residential placement or at
risk of placement um are able to be
assigned councel at the discretion of
the Court um and to just refer back to
some of the other questions that were
asked earlier comments that were made
earlier um I do think it's important to
recognize that the resarch research does
not tell us that children being present
at a a judicatory hearing is going to be
traumatizing there are many instances
for some children where it'll actually
be a healing process for them especially
if they are able to see their
perpetrator held accountable for what
they have done to them um so we don't
have an outstanding amount of research
that says that that is negative and
impactful um process for them to
participate in um and I do feel strongly
that their attorney should be a part of
that um and have an opportunity to voice
what the child wants um like others said
before me I do believe that the judges
have the ability to differentiate the
fact that many children do want to go
home and love their parents because that
is all they know but understand the
facts of abuse and neglect and when it
is safe and appropriate to remove them
from that setting
I did also want to speak on the question
about the cat assessments from
representative long it is my
understanding that the now that the
program has been in full swing for quite
some time now there have not been many
delays in getting those assigned um they
are sent out timely Maximus has the
Staffing currently to be able to keep up
and and do those assessments so I I do
believe that time of referral for the
cat assess assment is critical for the
notification to the court for an
attorney to be assigned um there are
unfortunately many times still that my
offices is receiving complaints from the
community in regards to placement of
children High numbers of children going
to Residential Care where there is
adequate family available that has not
been explored and I think that is the
critical piece of having the attorney
involved from the very beginning of of
that process so they can Advocate and uh
you know there are times that a a child
may get so the the cat scores is five is
the highest and n one is the lowest and
there are times that a child could have
a three or four cat assessment but
residential placement may still not be
the most appropriate placement for them
I have met with many children who do
better in smaller settings family like
settings as opposed to Residential
Treatment settings and so although the
cat may be saying they have difficulties
that need to be met at that higher level
with a small smaller environment and the
appropriate Community Based supports
they can be more successful than being
placed in a residential facility and I
do believe there are times where an
attorney can adequately voice that to
the court and ensure that that placement
is truly being reviewed before a child
is sent there I also did want to share
some of my personal experience um before
coming to New Hampshire I worked in
Massachusetts and in the state of
Massachusetts every child is assigned an
attorney at the beginning of the process
and throughout to to the end and this
was not just children residential care
but it was all children and I felt even
being on the other side at the time I
was working for DCF and I felt that they
were able to advocate for the children
appropriately they were able to have
some of those conversations some of
those difficult conversations that came
up earlier around um child's expressed
interest but what's in their best
interest and from my experience the
attorneys did a very good job of
ensuring that they voiced the child's
expressed interest in court but then
also discussed a backup plan so with the
child if yes you want to go with Mom and
Dad if that cannot happen then what and
then the child may say oh so and so
relative so then in court they are
saying first and foremost this child
wants to remain with family but if
that's not possible and the division is
going to be winning their case here the
child would like to ensure that this
particular family member is adequately
explored and and so they are able to to
somewhat represent both and I do think
that um skilled attorneys as long as
they have the the appropriate training
to do that um Can ensure that they
maintain that trusting relationship with
the child and truly clarify and and
Advocate and voice for what they want in
court while ensuring that there is also
an appropriate backup plan knowing that
much of the time going back home may not
be an
option representative long thank you Mr
chairman um so a couple things uh so we
we're just talking about uh residential
placement yes with respect to the
attorney okay so not not all um now did
did you say the data doesn't show uh
added trauma to the kids or there's no
data it does not it there is the
research right now does not
outstandingly say that it is additional
trauma to the child by being present at
a adjudicatory hearing um there is some
research and support of children
attending these types of hearings okay
um and
uh and also what uh piqu my attention uh
that an
attorney uh may drive towards family
placement it seems that seems very
reasonable to me that that could happen
um and that's what your you've
experienced in mass is that um instead
of residential placement they went
either with a family member or somebody
else yes yes I have had the experience
where attorneys have been able to get
children placed in homes and it it does
work a bit different there where um the
department in Massachusetts could not
approve them as a foster home because of
certain barriers um and it could be
something as simple as the space they
have in their home and to be a foster
home it requires certain space and so at
that point the attorney would advocate
for the child to still go to that
placement knowing that they could
provide the adequate care and maybe
would have to uniquely change around
their configurations of their house to
be able to fit the child in there and so
those are some of the situations that I
saw where attorneys were very successful
and keeping the child in a least
restrictive setting with family that the
state was unable to do okay thank
you representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here today
I was hoping you would come what is the
definition of at risk like is there an
atrisk defined here that we would be we
did not come up with a definition of at
risk rather we pointed in in this
amendment here um to when we understand
that the the dcyf would be moving
towards seeking out these types of
placements and as um Lisa Wolford
mentioned before I was president up here
it is in their policy um that they're
there comes a time where they are
sending a a a cat referral out as well
as the child's um case packet they may
call it where it has all information
about the child to seek out placement
and so that is what we were leaning into
as at risk because that is the
understanding that that is our
understanding of the way in which the
division already operates when they are
looking for place placement Beyond
foster care or kinship
care that's
it m m Sanchez I'm I'm Sorry Miss
Sanchez let make sure I address you
correctly no no problem uh the the issue
as specific to HB 535 as
introduced what does that not do that
one of the Amendments that we have
before us will allow that flexibility to
do in meeting the child's needs for
representation the importance of that is
ensuring that children who are in
placement would have access to an
attorney because we do understand these
are our most vulnerable children that
are in that level of care and if we are
not specifying that um specifically
those either in residential placement or
at risk of residential placement would
have an attorney then we are missing our
most vulnerable youth having the
appropriate representation to ensure
their needs are being met appropriately
of course we do have Casa in place who
can advocate for their best interest but
um it is really important the a a point
that was made before me it is really
important to ensure that our children
feel they have a voice and that they are
heard this is a process where their
entire life is being controlled by
adults that they don't know um it's hard
enough for children to adjust in a world
and grow up where their life is
controlled by their parents whom they
know well and they have an understanding
of what the expectations are in that
home but to have strangers who they are
unfamiliar with is very unsettling and
um what we see for a lot of children is
when there's that unknown and someone
else has control over their life they
seek out other areas of their life where
they can take control and often that
does display and risky
Behavior so so that with that statement
being
heard the bill as written does not
provide
that access to
representation as it states in here
where it says it shall be entitled to
representation of
council it does not um because it does
not
specify when they shall be and um and
especially that that piece of those at
risk is not those in placement and those
at risk of placement is not clarified
there and so it leaves a lot of
discretion to the court without
identifying those most atrisk
Youth and and then one followup with you
is the amendment I mean we have two
amendments before
us the narrative that you refer to that
would give give this strength to the
application of Law and spec of law
specific to
representation which lines do that in
the amend in and the the amendment from
uh the the jrpg draft yes it would be in
there um and we have in um
2B and it is
[Music]
the um so down a little lower where it
says such notification so about Midway
um such notification shall occur prior
to referral for an independent
assessment or sub submission of child
specific information
to such
placement is where it speaks about that
that time frame to notify the court to
request an attorney um as well as that
that additional place down there um
where it says the line following in case
of an emergency NES necessitating
immediate placement of a child um that
they shall notify the court within two
business days and so that is um ensuring
that the court is notified as closely as
possible and within a reasonable time
frame for the division to meet them that
um to be able to assign attorney but it
also leaves space for the division to
act in an emergency and place a child if
the only option is residential at that
time they have the ability to do that
while the attorney is getting
assigned okay and the reason I was
bringing this up since we um I'm
grateful that we received this when we
did but uh the butt is is dealing with
RS say one 1 70 and not 169 and as a
result this see that the difference
between the two I just have 169 in front
of us and not 170 to see what where
we're coming uh deficient so that so
that what's recommended will have the
appropriate uh result that is being
advocated here and that's to look after
our our the CH our children the the
minors and I just want to clarify from a
minor standpoint it's there's 18 is
majority age at the moment what's the
other side of that is it and from age
one on it it would be birth but our
residential if we're talking about
specifically those in placement children
in placement typically range from 5 to
six years up um ideally it should be 12
up but um we have seen children as young
as five or six placed in residential
facilities um I would like to clarify as
well um the important insertion in 170g
is to inform the children of their right
um which I believe is is very critical
to include here um because and again
it's not saying that it guarantees them
a right to an attorney but it is just to
inform the child and and add this to the
children's Bill of Rights because if
this is a right that children have they
should be aware of that they should be
informed and have the ability to know
when to ask for an attorney and when I
was just shown by my colleagues here was
uh the uh age of majority is to 21 not
18 and that's dealing with the mental
health challenges so I wanted to make
make sure that that is then concurrent
with what your expertise is yes there is
an extension to 21 for for those um
develop disabilities as well as those
that um choose to sign on into um after
care but they they then have some
decision-making power with that um but
there is also a a differentiator for
those that have disability and are
placed by schools that would actually go
to
22 okay and uh one one additional
question ask again we want an open
concept here for guidance from our
professionals we have the another draft
amendment that was in effect taken out a
sentence uh did you you did you get a
copy of that or do you have a copy of of
that one is this are you referring to a
prior amendment that was was worked on
between the groups or are you referring
to the the casa amendment that was no we
just referred one today from froma um so
so yes the casa Amendment um does not
speak in depth to um those children that
are in need of placement or at risk of
placement and my understanding is as
they share today um there's some
reservation around some of that um
defining of that and when it's
appropriate for those attorneys to
participate in
hearings okay and just a clarification
from from for me is when it states to
represent the and the Word was moved
from one part of the existing law to
here the expressed interest of the child
what's the definition of
expressed so the expressed interest
would be the interest in which the child
is stating themselves rather than what
which what Casa represents is the best
interest of child which is taking taking
into account what is appropriate for
them
developmentally um and safety wise which
is also um the office of the child
advocate also operates to ensure the
best interest of children is protected
so those two can differentiate that's
where we're talking about those
situations where a child may want to go
home to their parent that is their
expressed interest but it is not in
their best interest for safety purposes
to go to that
setting and that would be also at an
adjudicatory
hearing as it stands in their Amendment
my understanding is that that is not to
be at the adjudicatory hearing okay and
just so I'm clear myself because it's
always a moving Target here what's the
definition of a judicatory hearing I am
the one of the only non-attorneys in the
room so I am going to pass it off to
someone else finally I got a question
you
couldn't but yeah no just hold right
there but yeah like
toire Legal Assistant so um the
definition of an adjudicatory hearing is
the trial so it's the trial to determine
whether or not the child was abused or
neglected um the the amendment would
allow representation at any stage of the
proceeding If the child is at risk of uh
going to residential placement so that
could potentially be either at or prior
to the adjudicatory hearing if the court
has removed the child from the home and
placed them in residential or there has
been a request to do that prior to the
adjudicatory hearing and so there are
two touch points the preliminary hearing
right the adjudicatory hearing and then
there's the dispositional hearing which
is like the sentencing like what's going
to happen going forward okay wanted to
make sure the definition hadn't changed
here but thank you very much for that
and um Miss Sanchez we we have
representative Greg has a question for
you so in your experience before you
worked in Massachusetts where you had a
lot the attorneys for children um was
there also an organization like was Casa
there as well yes they they were not as
widespread as Casa is here in New
Hampshire but yes they they do exist
they have Massachusetts chapter as well
so what does that cooperation look like
as far as if a are they still involved
like if a child has an attorney then
Casa is still involved I'm just looking
at what this looks like if we have
attorneys for these kiddos and what does
that what does that cooperation look
like absolutely that is actually a great
question um they do they would have both
um but again in Massachusetts they were
not always given a casa it would be
appointed by a judge I can share
especially in the work that my office
has done closely with the office of the
child advocate in Massachusetts that one
of the recommendations that came out
from their Harmony Montgomery report was
for there to be Casas and attorneys for
every child and I think that's really
critical right because it is important
for to honor the child and ensure that
their expressed interest is heard in the
court but it is also critical that their
best interest be represented in the
court and a partnership between the two
working together for the child is when
we see the best work done and the most
successful outcomes and so with the work
that they did and
reviewing how Harmony was placed with
her father they recognized that in that
case there was an attorney but the
missing link was also having a casa rep
representation so I I do believe and and
hold firm in my conversations with with
them and their full assessment of of how
the court proceedings played out in
Massachusetts that it is very pertinent
that we make sure we maintain the casa
program while adding these attorneys to
advocate for the
children thank you Miss Sanchez thank
you with there any any other
comments what's that oh there you
are good afternoon Representatives I'm
Erin krian I'm the general counsel for
the New Hampshire judicial branch um I I
thank everyone for for having sent me
their their drafts since your last
meeting um and for accurately
representing what I told them which is
that of course the courts don't stand in
the shoes of the legislature when it
comes to making a policy decision uh you
weigh these interests and you write the
law and we will apply uh what you write
and we typically limit our commentary to
issues of what the court can do and can
enforce and whether there is a question
for us about what you are intending and
what you want to have happen when the
statute is applied um typically I would
say the larger the change in the law the
the better it would be to have great
guidance from the legislature about what
it is that you want to change and what
you want to see the judges doing um in
saying this I'm not saying that this is
not an issue that is extremely important
to the judges that work in this area
that they're not extremely passionate
and that ultimately when you weigh all
these interests you might not find that
one one policy alternative is superior
even maybe vastly superior to the other
it's we're we're not commenting because
it's not our place but not necessarily
because we're telling you that these are
the same or that we're indifferent to
the result um it is it is
constitutionally committed to you to
answer this question within our role of
how do these things impact the courts as
I look over some of the drafts um
certainly the draft that says that there
will be discretionary appointments is
one that the courts can easily
administer it is not confusing to us
what is being sought in that draft uh
looking at some of the other drafts um I
think there are questions and I think
you've heard them come up in the
conversation today that there's a term
that will be interpreted by the courts
that the courts will decide what this
will be um you know for example just
taking an example of
emergency if you have a vision of what
it is that you want that to be or to not
be or if you want it to be committed to
the discretion of the court or committed
to the discretion of DCF guidance from
you would be very helpful uh I think one
of of the issues that's been raised is
that there are not very many Attorneys
at this time that that do this kind of
work and so it is possible that there
would be a situation where the statute
calls for mandatory appointment and
there's no attorney available if that's
the case what is the guidance that the
legislature wants to give the courts on
what we would do at that
point um if there is going to be an
attorney representing the expressed
interest of the child in a hearing on
their best interests are is the
legislature envisioning that at some
point the courts could find the express
interest trumps the best interest or are
you envisioning that the expressed
interests would always defer to the best
interest uh if you're not expecting that
the attorney for the child would
participate in a judicatory hearing
would they file a motion to participate
would there be a
standard like a low one or a high one
extraordinary circumstances that would
need to be demonstrated there are
questions here that I think we do have
because it if this were implemented
there would be changes in the way that
things are done and we want to make sure
we implement the vision that you have of
how these problems should be solved uh
because although you can solve them by
committing some of them to our
discretion um we may read your silence
on the issue as mandating a different
result or anticipating a different
result uh so I I appreciate all of the
consider a that you've given to this
issue it is a very complicated issue it
as as these different groups have
discussed how to address these problems
there is a lot that they have brought up
for each other that I think was very
productive and I appreciated reading
about it and I think uh they are some
good points to be made but there are
still questions that the court would
have in how to implement the vision that
you have for what the policy in this
area should be and so I I want to flag
that for you that is our limited um
ability to offer information to in this
area representative long thank you Mr
chairman you probably you probably can't
answer this now but if if we could
possibly get an answer um in your
opinion do you believe this would be
helpful on behalf of the judges or the
court system when you say this well like
like uh
about um attorneys being appointed uh
for children just like I asked you about
the parental uh yesterday's you know I'm
looking to
relieve you know we already know that
the judges hands a full uh for many
reasons and I'm looking to relieve that
do you think that this would be one of
those
AIDS uh with helping the judge determine
issues
that is a very difficult question I do
think that when I first reviewed the
language about offering more types of
discretionary appointment it's hard to
see how that would be harmful because if
the court ever thought it was harmful in
any particular circumstance they would
not appoint so it's difficult to see
what a negative side of that would be uh
in terms of a mandatory appointment it's
not necessarily a negative but if you
don't have an attorney available or they
are allowed to argue Express interests
versus best interest it raises questions
for the judge that might be difficult to
deal with so I I don't want to suggest
that it would always no matter what is
provided if there's an expansion of
attorney rights that it would be easy
for the courts to administer um but
certainly in terms of offering more
discretion it's hard to see how there's
a downside on discretion we just want to
make sure that we would appropriately
handle any mandatory requirements that
you impose okay thank
you
Miss it's krian yes sir I want to make
sure I said that correctly um Miss krian
in the um the bill there's a fiscal note
that has all zeros in it because there
there's but there's a very I believe a
strong comment from the judicial Council
stating what the challenges are and and
what what you just recounted if I may is
what is being stated in the in that
section of the proposed
Bill and without speaking for the
judicial Council they do pay for these
attorneys right now the parental
attorneys who are appointed so it's it's
very likely they their funds that would
be implicated if there's an expansion of
appointments so they the issues they
raise in terms of availability of either
funds or attorneys are are certainly um
issues which they're poised to comment
on and as uh as representative long has
stated clearly
we have a judge capacity issue uh to
meet the cases outside of having a a
wait list that could go on at nauseum I
would I would imagine is um do you have
would you have any guidance relative to
the gal uh Silo of resources being
expanded versus an
attorney the attorney Silo when that's
if they're not available what is what
would be what is the the alternative
strategy when the representation is
clearly needed or there's there's no one
no one there in this case for the
subject subject that we're talking about
here the young young children that's a
tremendous challenge in terms of funding
the the limited resources that a state
always has to spend and how it spends
them and also our National Labor
shortage there is no area that is not
impacted by a lack of talent a lack of
people that we can attract into public
service while they're very very very
desirable in private service I was uh
talking today and seeking to answer some
questions from a hearing yesterday about
Guardians Ed lium about our current um
status of the guardian of lighten
program and we have not been taking in
new recruits very frequently for the
last few years um it has been a
challenge attracting the the the gardens
that let them that appear in the
parenting cases typically that are
typically paid by the parties we just
have not been able to attract a lot of
new people into that profession so that
is a that is a challenge I'm not sure
that you wouldn't a shortage in other
areas as well but we certainly do have
some institutions that already exist we
have Guardians at light and we have a
certifying board we have CA there are
there are structures that exist um but
you're right we're impacted by a
resource and and a and a Personnel issue
in many
areas and that being stated is and
passing know and passing a methodology
to meet the this challenge that we have
without appropriate fun funding and let
alone if the funding's there if you
don't have the the Professional
Resources individuals to fill that
need how are we meeting that how is that
being met
now I my understanding in terms of the
the parenting attorneys who typically
appear under the statute's current
requirements to appoint parents have
just been decreased by about two that I
think went to go work for GCF and I know
that we are we are facing a very real
possibility that we are not going to
meet some of the existing mandatory
appointments in the very near future we
certainly hope that won't happen and I
know that there are are folks that are
working on recruiting people and and
trying to get more talent but that was
one of the things that we notice um with
this proposal speaking not at all on
whether it is a good policy idea is the
courts probably will need guidance on
what they do if there is not an attorney
available for a mandatory
appointment and then they
uh a unique opportunity to have have you
here for this so you got gu is on
reading the bill along with our
professionals do we need to make a
change on this right now I want ask you
right now do we need better services for
our children for children
families if we don't if we don't have
these in other resources to support it
where it's like a false commitment
unless we have the com the funding and
the the have the professionals ready to
be there when the when the judge uh
makes makes that DEC makes a decision
for representation for the children in
these
uh in these family court cases that's a
great question I you you have
Alternatives I wouldn't want to direct
you as as to how to handle those issues
whether you would want to handle one
part of the issue first and and then
expand from there I I I couldn't say the
the best way for you to handle that
challenge but I think it is a challenge
and it's one that I know some of the
folks have flagged as well which is you
have your idea of what might be the
perfect system and you have the question
of whether you would um Implement that
as soon as possible in a a well-funded
Consolidated measure or whether you
would try to do interim measures and
work towards something which might have
the advantage of giving you some
feedback on what works and whether there
are unexpected challenges but also has a
negative that you're not necessarily
getting everything that you want right
away um that that's that is a very
difficult question I do not envy the
situation that you are in in
uh that change well one one last point
to have to get the benefit of your
guidance on uh and I'll preclude it with
this comment in in all bills there's a
May and a shall and uh in this in the
bill as
presented it was saying that there may
be a appointment and then that but at
the end it then it shall be there's a
shall be entitled you're entitled but
you may be a
pointed is is when we're looking at
making a recommendation here should the
word shall be a standard to ensure the
uh I call the different silos of
responsibility know they have to perform
so there's not a I change my mind I
don't need to do it even though even
though others directed you needed to
until it comes to a criteria that says
if it's not available and by available
meaning for funding you know and if the
funding is not there to provide the
resources what's your view on that there
we certainly Implement both types of
statutes we Implement statutes that have
a May um and give discretion uh or wait
till resources are in place and we
Implement some statutes which are an
absolute lock that something has to be
done it shall be done the legislature
has decided that the courts should not
have discretion in that area and some of
those are extremely appropriate uh so
not suggesting that you would never need
a sh um to say you shall appoint uh an
attorney for an Indigent criminal
defendant that that shall happen
absolutely uh if you do not have the
resources in place I could see that that
would be difficult so if if you are
going to mandate that the court shall do
something and the resource is not
available I would suggest giving an
alternative for what the court would do
if there's if that resource is not
available yeah it's interesting what
that you just referred to was shall for
Indigent criminals but may for children
there are many there are many issues
like this in our law that the
requirement to have an attorney for an
Indigent criminal defendant is in the us
and state constitution so it is not
something that the legislature could
choose to obate if they wanted to that
is something that we must do or else we
will have the case will the conviction
if there is one will not stand um this
is an issue which I understand that
states have there is not a
constitutional mandate which is not to
say that one could not be passed by our
citizens or ultimately interpreted to
exist but at this moment there is not
one um and so it is committed to the
legislator's discretion which again is
not to say that there is not something
you will determine that Justice requires
be done in the case um but that is that
is a distinction legally between those
two different
situations thank you very much uh
representative long thank you Mr
chairman so I think I heard you say that
if it's discretionary then uh make clear
our intent uh so we're getting what we
intended to get uh okay and also um with
respect to the effective date they like
to see the beginning January of the
following year so so any effective date
should be January of 2024 January first
does that give enough time well it
probably wouldn't give enough time yeah
it' be 25 okay yeah if you're looking at
January 2025 in terms of our training of
our judges I believe we could do it in
that time period in terms of making sure
that you go through the budgetary
process with regard to the needs of the
judicial Council will have in funding um
I would defer to you I think you may
have more information about how you
would ensure that the mandates that you
have are
funded okay thank you thank
you I just was going to make a comment
on that is I found it just in the past
that when there is a new uh requirement
for spending it's the next budget cycle
so it's what we we put the policy in
place but it's moot if it requires a
funding uh component until the budget is
heard and
that's why
25 or or the next budget cycle unless
there's a executive order to move money
from a from one location to another we
fund
it thank you very much thank you did we
finally stimulate you to say
something put that button yeah thank you
thank you my name is Jay Bucky I'm
currently the deputy director of the
judicial Council um as I was saying I
don't have a name tag yet because I'm
quite new taking over for Richard San
perel uh and I'll take over as executive
director on November 2nd and uh of
judicial Council judicial Council yes um
wanted to add just a couple things since
I heard our agency mentioned our my main
role to is to listen to the legislation
see what the impact would be but I want
to add a couple things since the fiscal
note had been referenced and just a
little bit of more Nuance in terms of
the uh for the judicial Council the
degrees of appointment and what that
language would necessarily mean and I'll
just start off um briefly by talking
about for the judicial Council the big
difference between uh a right to counsel
one moment are you an attorney yes sir
okay attorney uh let's see Buckingham
move that mic right to your face now
okay I don't want anyone to miss your
word words here okay thank you as you
can tell it's my first time at this desk
so I can't uh great
um so for our agency the difference
would be um between having a right to
counsel and then a right to appoint a
counsel that would be a major difference
in terms of expending resources just by
way of analogy um the way I think it
might be helpful to think about it is
for people who are accused of speeding
tickets um DUIs you know minor
misdemeanors like that you have a right
to counsel in those cases if you can
afford a lawyer you have a right to have
one in those cases um however in a class
A misdemeanor case or a felony case you
have the right to appointed Council
which was what was referenced by uh
attorney krian um so that would be the
difference in the language that would
matter for resources because if someone
has a right to appointed Council then
obviously our agency would have an
obligation to expend resources to uh
fund those attorneys so that that
language would be very important if
there's a right to an attorney um but
but it's not a right to to an appointed
attorney our read of that would be you
wouldn't have the right to have state
funds expended for that attorney unless
we received um some other order to the
contrary
um in terms of uh in terms of funding
generally I think our fiscal note was
that the funding was indeterminant and
that was
because um the way it's currently
written is it didn't create a new right
to appointed Council if it did obviously
that would create a more substantial
need resources however I would know that
there would be you know regardless uh of
whether that language is included or not
anytime there's a uh a new right to
council or a new opportunity for Council
to be appointed that would uh
necessitate an addictional expenditure
of resources and I think you all already
touched on the need for having an
additional time period so that we could
seek funding and have that approved so
that would be available and also to uh
seek and procure additional training
resources for attorneys because that
would be appointed excuse me important
uh I think it's it's been mentioned
already that there is and continues to
be uh an issue with obtaining lawyers
who provide these services and cases
obviously they're important cases and
having the right training and the right
attorneys is also important um but
finding the appropriate attorneys to
take these kinds of cases throughout the
state it can be difficult you know
there's not especially in more rural
parts of the state it can be hard to
find attorneys who will take these cases
so um there is a resource issue there
and um whatever the you know the
legislature decides to do we will do our
best to execute that Vision um but I
just wanted to provide a bit of context
there in terms of the different degrees
of what level of funding what level of
resources be required based on what's
passed thank you attorney Buckingham and
um do you have a copy of the the five
house pill 535 in nearby for
you no I don't believe I do okay well go
from memory then maybe you read it but
um when it when you were saying the
difference between the right to council
and the right to you say appointed or
appointive appointed appointed councel
that would need you recommend that we
and looking how to move something
forward here is to put language in law
that made that right if that's a
definite cause and effect that when
asked it shall
happen by by how you describe it am I or
or not just just to be clear I think at
this point I would just say that it
would make a difference in terms of the
resources necessary so if if it's
written that there's a right to have a
lawyer appointed then that would be one
thing if there's a right to counsel
that' be another thing or do I have
sorry
just just the last oh did the attorney
give you a copy I she pointed out that I
didn't I was looking at the statute not
the House books excuse me oh oh well yes
I have it the house bill is the
authority having jurisdiction yes thank
you thank you for supporting
that that I just to go to the last the
last line uh well well it's three um
where it says the council indicates Etc
there's there's two sentences right
there and it was just where the bill
does not direct a court to appoint
counsel and does not include a public
funding source for such representation
that's when when you're providing your
guidance there that would be something
that would need to be in in a a bill
narrative to ensure that this does take
place and then would require funding to
be
present was am I saying that that's what
that's directing us yes exactly so if if
the intent was to create a right to an
appointed to appointed counsel that
language would need to be explicit and
and have to be changed and and by
explicit just to get your guidance here
what else uh would
need would need to be added to that oh
it might say not to this per se but the
comment of um the right
to to appoint
Council and then to ensure that the
funding is there because then it's moved
otherwise the funding wouldn't be there
to pay for
it when what narrative would need to be
in the bill for that to happen would
would you have a recommendation on that
I think um in the first instance i'
probably want to take a look and consult
with the current executive director and
maybe provide a written resp response to
with our suggested language again at
this point I wouldn't be taking a
position either way but we could
certainly provide a written response
that which would indicate what language
we would uh we would read as creating a
right to appointed Council yeah I asked
that because I wouldn't want it to be
quote under appeal after the fact you
know when it said well you didn't ask
the authority right here like yourself
on how what would be a correct narrative
should this move forward so that's why I
was asking uh your guidance in that
regard certainly I I can also take a
moment moment right now to uh consult
with the chair of the judicial council
is here as well I could consult with her
and get back to you but I do think
perhaps our you know in terms of my
preference today since we don't we
didn't prepare a revised version we can
only point out what our understanding of
the law is as written we certainly be
happy if the count if the committee
would like us to come up with language
that would mandate an attorney we could
do that whether or not the committee
should do that obviously that's up to
you but we could certainly provide
language that we think would be
unambiguous
well what we have uh we have the uh
children and family law is uh making a
recommendations on this retained bill in
on the 31st of
October is uh so then I ask is that
something you could get to the
subcommittee certainly uh prior I mean
as quickly as possible so and then we
can we'll decide well they decide what's
that the next steps to do sure then we
can get that we can get that J on that n
very quickly yes right thank you
attorney Buckingham oh it's attorney
Bucky just Bucky oh bucky bucky yes
where' I get Buckingham
from I I I like Buckingham a lot but I I
don't know well the Castle's open I can
tell you it does sound better but it's
but your last name is Bucky Bucky yes oh
man I was way
off sorry about that no problem at all
yeah you faded at the end you went Bucky
all right you know that was it I get
that right the first time all right was
any anything f for attorney
Bucky
okay I just wanted to add sort of a
little context because it might help um
give you a sense of of some of the
numbers Kasa currently has
127 Children and Youth that are placed
in residential
facilities um so and we estimate that we
have about 75 to 80% % of those total
numbers of children from Ab only
involved in abuse and neglect
proceedings 127 are in residential
facilities the new director of DCF is
very committed and I think Cassandra
could speak to this too to um
eliminating as many residential
placements as possible and putting those
kids into foster care kinship care or
other resources within their their
community so there is that movement but
just so you have some con text of what
the numbers of attorney
representation um for kids for Children
and Youth and residential it that's what
our numbers are at this at this present
time 127 127 children that are in
residential placement yeah and is that
in New Hampshire only that's new H well
no some of the 39 of those children and
I and that that in those numbers are
about two weeks old so it may have
changed but we are really working hard
at getting our children who are in outof
State placement back to either placement
within the New England region or within
the state of New Hampshire so um that's
and that is happening we're seeing more
kids coming home so third but at the mo
at the moment not at the moment it's 39
out of state it's 127 in residential
whether in state or out of state or
within New England um but 39 of those
are Beyond are outside of the the state
so just to keep that number in mind it
just gives you a sense of what potential
attorney how many attorneys we could be
looking at if this is mandatory um
without developing a pool of of
well-trained and qualified attorneys in
advance of that
so rep representative long yeah just
with respect to both proposals are they
replacing the whole
bill uh it looks like it looks like um
that was yeah that was attorney
rosenberg's is that was the intent okay
so yours is I think that the the jpg1
just kind of amends the first section of
the original Bill and then takes out the
second section and replaces that second
section with new language okay thank
you anything further uh from all our
professionals
here you're laughing already what
happened you've had
enough oh jeez I'm not feeling the love
all of a sudden what happened it's not
all crystal clear
now if we could just talk in general
without asking anyone questions you guys
have been so gracious with us on all of
our questions and thank you you know I
have to the rest of my um subcommittee
here
um you know obviously this is this is an
issue and gosh even there's a story on
Netflix right now taking care of Maya
where a girl was um you know taken from
her mom and you know lots of different
things and so I have concerns about
cases like that not only where kids are
sometimes rightfully taken out of an
abusive home but also when they're
unfortunately taken out of a home they
shouldn't be where they're you know a
doctor may be overreacting or there's a
lot of different
cases you know when we get into this I I
keep saying this it's like aable you
like think you get a piece of it and
then it seems to grow at bare minimum we
have to take this 30-day window out we
have to let the judges you know be able
to do this whenever I am highly
concerned about you know what in the J
jrpg draft also um I do think that we
need something like that I'm I'm so
concerned about our limited resources we
have in New
Hampshire and saying shall and what
that's going to do you know in a perfect
world we would say okay every kiddo
should be able to do this I think that's
important especially if the lawyer is
working in concert with Casa you know or
the other child Advocates because I
think that's necessary we can't only
have a legal brain in there um I'm just
not I'm really I I think
I don't know what I think um there's a
lot of information here I I am worried
about resources and I think am I getting
that right and you can just say yes or
no Kasa that is your your one of your
largest concerns about this larger one
is the amount of resources that we have
and that we could hang this
up and this is another we have a lot of
well-intentioned bills that come to us
that in wanting to fix a lot of problems
we can make more problems S no matter
how we decide to do this especially
after just hearing from judicial
counsel if we don't word this exactly
right or if we don't have a sunset kind
of plan or something where we give our
ourselves time to build these
resources we can cause a massive problem
I do think it needs to happen I do think
that we need this representation for
children especially ones who are at risk
I think we've kind of defined enough in
here at least for me in this session
maybe not in the bill so much about what
that at risk looks like but I do know
that kids once they get into a treatment
that's its own trauma once they get like
in a residential treatment or whatever
whether or not we bring them back
immediately because it was a mistake or
we give them a lawyer once they're there
I think that's a problem because I think
that that is a trauma right there um
that particular thing I just we're not
there yet and I it's unfortunate that
there's a divide in the people that we
we really do look to you for a lot of
advice and I think it's all good advice
I don't think anybody's wrong in this I
think we have a complicated system with
our lack of funds our lack of funds our
lack of resources part of that is we're
a small state
um I just I I don't know what it takes
us to get to a final place but I do
think at the bare minimum we've got to
take off that 30-day restraint that we
currently have on judges um but anyway
that's just my kind of musings I guess
on
this um one just one quick question um
the 30-day 30-day issue where in the law
is that specifically so right now so
you'll see it on both of them where
they've crossed this out so it's by the
first
um where it is so it's by the first
uh gosh I don't even have it now I mean
yeah I'm was just looking at the so the
by the oh the dispositional orders so
dispositional orders is usually within
30 days that's why I said 30 days it
doesn't say 30 days it says
dispositional orders so right now as it
stands they would the judge would need
to do it by dispositional orders which
is generally within that first 30 days I
don't know if there's a legal
requirement that that be within the
first 30 days the dispositional
hearing is
there
any ERS so so the recommendation for
both sides to take that out so that it
can happen prior to the disposition
orders which is within 30 days of the
right exactly so that's the seat belt
yeah so right now there's a seat Bel on
our judges and I think some judges are
going above and beyond anyway but right
now that's not as clear so that's why I
say the 30 days I would hate to think
because a lot of cases when you have
abuse neglect you have other things
you're not going to find out in the
first 30 days it could take a few months
it could um kids as they're away from
their um abuser uh will tend to open up
as they realize that that's not normal
quote unquote that that's because that's
the only thing they know so so many
things come out after that first 30 days
that are imperative that we not have
that on there but anyway that's what
that was about oh well that being said
is if that now that's in rules because
thenu the rules aren't here this is
showing the policy and then there's the
application of the policy that's why I'm
I'm always Wonder know where that is but
if it's 30 days and all our
professionals here have said yes that's
the fact uh what um then what would you
recommend taking the place of that in
rules uh in the Court's rules is that
open-ended or or or what would a number
be well I'm not sure that we would need
because I this is one of those cases
where I think the judges who are seeing
all the different aspects of the case or
as many as are getting presented to them
it's their their discretion at that
point because we don't know um you know
maybe a kiddo has been sent to
Residential Treatment now we're three
years out or something you know that
they the judge should be able to say you
know wait a second we need to do this so
that would be their discretion I would
not put um a time constraint and
actually so kasa's Bill while it while I
do think it's bare minimum on what we
should do it does actually um in their
uh in 535 it takes that out or their
Amendment to 535 I don't know there's so
many amendments here but um it actually
takes that out you'll see where it takes
out for dispositional
orders
um so I don't think that we would put
another time constraint I'm not sure if
it would be helpful but basically the
casa Amendment currently 169
C10 um and I misplaced my glasses the 2A
2A the language only allows
a judge discretionary appointment um if
there is a conflict between what the
child and the guardian and lium
represent as stated interest and be best
interest and if there is a conflict with
the dispositional orders and as
representative Greg referenced the
dispositional hearing is in the early
part of the case so after the
preliminary hearing and the adjudicatory
hearing the very next hearing is the
dispositional hearing
there's a whole another potentially 12
months even years potentially that that
can happen in the life of a case so for
all all of us who are concerned in cases
where Casa has tried has filed motions
for Council to be appointed we're
sometimes three years into the case
where a child um disregulated could had
to be removed from multiple foster homes
and then was placed in an out ofate
facility and so we're even at this point
the that the parents rights may have
been terminated but that 169c case is
still open so here we are 3 years later
that child wants to come home Casa is
saying we want that child to come home
we think it's in the child's best
interest because current statute reads
there is no
conflict and we're beyond the
dispositional
hearing there are Judges who deny that
motion for counsel and say my hands are
tied we're too late in the case
and the the guardian at Liam and the
child
agree so I'm sorry M well where in law I
mean specifically because I'm not seeing
it in well I'm just looking at the
documents I have what's the number and
location for what you just
stated I just can't find my glasses one
c102
C all right so we're what we're what KAS
is requesting is some of that limiting
language to to be stricken and we think
it's a pretty easy statutory fix and by
taking out the language that we
recommend it would give judges
discretion to appoint Council for
children at any point in the case and
would give judges discretion to appoint
attorneys even if the guardian at Liam
and the child are on the same page and I
mean that's the example I'm giving
everybody agrees this child should be in
a a less restrictive environment but you
we're filing you know a motion for for
an attorney to be appointed and the
judge is saying we're too far along I
can't do it you want to see what your
comfort level is on on this one and and
that is the discretion issue uh for
judges has been a uh my my bias in the
discuss in multiple discussions on these
bills we've been seeing is what is that
um in question is how much discretion a
judge has and how much should be um
directed by by law
is this discretion in this case you're
that something you discretion as to when
an action would take place uh here you'd
be you're saying that that's the more
appropriate is to have the judges decide
how quickly or not how quickly u a
direction relative to dispositional
orders
notwithstanding where we are right now
yes I mean in our cases our judges are
they're there for every step of the way
and we feel with the lack of resources
now that the limited attorneys we have
should be appointed to those cases where
they're really needed that's where we
should start and the judges so parties
the child can ask the guardian at lium
can ask the parent can ask and judges
right now sitting in those cases have
discretion to say yep and we're we all
may be arguing to that uh but yes so
where we think we think it that's where
it should start okay and as rep Greg
pointed out relative to his 30 days is
is that the dis to use the word
discretion here for the judge could take
up to 30 days for a decision or in or
with taking it as this as we put it
right in as you're hearing in the
amendment what the law reads is whether
or not there's a conflict with the
dispositional orders and that happens to
occur at the time of the dispositional
hearing so the law doesn't reference 30
days from from the adjudicatory hearing
it just references the dispositional
orders so it's cas's position if that
language is just as stricken uh that we
would get to a really good first step so
that children right now who need
attorneys and we have kids right now who
really do but there are Judges who feel
their hands are tied that this law is
tying their hands and they can't appoint
and and just one clarification point
then is does that indicate that time's
of the essence
when you have this you know taken that
out that for the the sense of message to
to the the message that the status of uh
addressing these issues is as quickly as
possible KAS From kasa's perspective we
would like this we do think there are
children right now who would benefit
from Council Council right now Casa
files motions for Council to be
appointed in some cases they're
sometimes denied because because of this
law okay I'm not sure if that answered
your
question so yeah clarification on the uh
30 days we're looking at 60 days also so
is it placement at home that's 30
days I I'm not sure what where the day
reference is coming from uh 169 C 15 is
that C15 y col 15
the we're referencing that particular
part of 169 days that they're still at
home but 30 days they've been taken up I
mean I I guess from kasa's perspective
the the Striking of the language would
make it clear that that there shouldn't
be Court the hearings unfortunately are
not always scheduled exactly when they
should be um so having a day limitation
in it I'm not sure would be
helpful oh well you were
successful yeah I come on up so we
you I don't think that there is a
limitation on dates I think the 30 days
sort have got a little bit confused
because um the the dis we just know that
the dispositional order is within 30
days of the judicatory I think we can
put 30 days aside and just say that the
ca Amendment would allow discretionary
appointment of council at any stage of
the proceedings and I think we don't
need to talk about the 30 or 60 days
because I just don't think it's relevant
to that analysis I do just want to put
forward one one maybe alternative one of
the things that I've been hearing
throughout this is that there's a lot of
agreement on the policy the policy of
what's in the best interest of kids um
and and you've heard that from certainly
the folks that I work with from the OCA
and even from Casa that there's a lot of
agreement that attorneys can add value
to this process and that the issue
really seems to be a resource constraint
as opposed to a dispute about the policy
which I think puts us in a really good
place and so one thing I think the
committee could consider is doing the
discretionary appointment of council so
taking that first piece and making an
effective date now you know within the
next you know within the next year
January 1st 2024 but then um put push
out an effective date of a mandatory
appointment because I think what the
concern of of lawyers are is that
lawyers aren't going to train up to do
this work unless they know that they're
going to be there's going to be work for
them to do and so if there's an
effective date that's pushed out that
would give us the opportunity to say
lawyers there are there's work for you
coming in the next couple of years let
us get you trained let us work with the
law school there's lots of lawyers
sitting in this room willing to train up
new lawyers to do this work and so if
that date of the mandatory right is
pushed out we wouldn't run up
necessarily against um a restriction on
whether or not a mandatory appointment
would actually result in an attorney
because there's nothing available but we
could work really hard to make that
happen when I hear 150 cases the case
load at the public defender office is
120 at any given time I don't think
that's a good number um I think it
should be much lower but we're talking
about two maybe three lawyers we're not
talking the the the number 150 sounds
like a lot but in terms of litigating
these types of cases there are lawyers
who handle a lot higher case loads and
do a pretty good job um so I don't think
it's unmanageable so I just want to to
throw that out there as an option since
I'm hearing a lot of agreement on
policy Miss uh Michelle wangr sorry New
Hampshire legal
assistance spell your last name it's w n
g r i
n
yes um just what we provided just am I
doing uh be quick here where it said
under 169 C15 hearings must be held
within 60 days from filing unless the
child is out of the home and then it's
30 days right but this would this the
first part of the amendment would allow
appointment of councel at any stage so
it it could be at the preliminary
hearing it could be at the adjudicatory
hearing it could be at the dispositional
it could be at a review hearing so I
don't think under this amendment that
everyone agrees on I don't think there's
a timing
issue if you notice on the jrpg they
actually he took out the exact same
thing that cost a debt on the other one
so that this is something that there is
an agreement on this is not a split the
baby this is like everybody agrees but I
do think that it's a bare minimum at
this point like I don't it doesn't solve
all the issues I do actually like the
idea of pushing out this other mandatory
part to where we can make sure we're
building resources we certainly can't
spring it on everybody but um it is a
bare minimum start I do like that there
is agreement on
that and the definition of bare minimum
is the amendment from Kasa
Kasa we like to think of it as a good
first
start that's a the first step First Step
because start goes to a stop immediately
when you leave the room good first step
yeah okay anything so yeah if I can just
comment thank you Mr chairman uh so I on
the other hand I look at policy period
policy pure policy what is in the best
interest of the child I'm not concerned
of what the cost is is I I just need to
know what the general court thinks is in
the best interest um I speak to a lot of
people uh uh talking about the Sonona
Youth Center you know it's costing us a
million dollars a child I say fantastic
as long as that million dollars is
delivering opportunities for that child
that child deserves that million dollars
in my opinion um so hopefully we
can hopefully we can um come to a
consensus between us that we could
advise the full committee uh and
reaching a consensus to where
um like like representative uh Greg said
there's still some improvement that we
could we could do now um not the whole
bite uh but not the smaller of the piece
either um so I think there's some um
absolute best interest interest uh that
that we should be able to deliver to
these uh
kids
okay would you like to hear
representative
Goan another quality decision by our
staff
member
myself
I think that we had the professionals
come in and tell us um what their
Viewpoint was they put something in
front of us that they believe is going
to address issues right now that need to
be addressed in the court and I'm um I'm
for supporting what I'm being given so
the larger I'm just wondering if there's
a way like you said to break it up and
then having the two different start
dates um for one and then the other but
I don't I just want to make sure that we
don't take this hard work that they've
done and forget that it was put in front
of us so I would love um we have some
other avenues that we can look at um as
far as getting the second half through
um if that's not a possibility then I
would I would prefer to um take the
larger bite and address the issues at
hand
uh Mr chairman move moving forward um it
looks like we may schedule another
meeting I mean I'm fine with that this
this is important enough for me I'll do
three meetings tues um okay so we'll
schedule another meeting and we have
answers coming forward I believe from uh
oh attorne attorney Bucky yeah Buckley
Buckley or when it's regal it's Buck oh
it's
Bucky
okay and what was there questions from
Aaron
yeah okay
super what' you
say well what what what we have uh to do
that I guess what we have as a challenge
here is there is uh our our deadlines
and it's only can be one amendment by
the way right that uh that we uh can do
and and uh the uh 31st is for the the
recommendation before the the committee
on what that Amendment uh would be and
that's how how now that being said I
I'll just make my comment on this when
it comes down there to the financial
issues that
will that uh well no we can it it's well
let me offer this to you it's um I'm one
that even though we're a policy
committee uh we're de facto a a funding
uh we're a finance committee also when
we know what what's the what we don't
know what these costs would be but that
would be the excuse not the excuse that
would be the rationale to do nothing
after a Bill's passed because the
funding isn't available and but in terms
of um what we saw first not first I mean
what's been presented here in our
discussion is uh like the amendment from
the caser amendment is doing something
at at the at the first thing uh for us
to offer for recommendation to have to
have this into a formal Amendment and
then it's in terms of these other issues
which are multi multifaceted here is I I
I'd say we need a study committee for it
and the and the reason is because of the
financial components that's that's the
reason if there's any of the policy
issues that could happen without having
a funding issue so there's not a reason
to delay what what's being recommended
and the reason being what we don't have
qu the money right I a little concern on
that then just one last comment is I I
had a similar thing in my uh previous
experience dealing with the uh uh
getting rid of the U developmental
disability weight list and that went
into a delay mode constantly but and
always a quality intent but the funding
wasn't there and candidly I was the
chair of the committee that then made it
give it a short version of reality when
we did the funding had the had the full
package it passed that we haven't had a
weight list issue for six seven terms
now um but it recognized is is not to
think hey we're doing half my words half
the job without doing the funding for it
and that's why I I was looking here
there's a consensus for us of what we
can do policy-wise that does not have a
fiscal
impact by by definition and uh and and
then having a a the study committee have
like the full commitment to have U for
next well for next year is to have this
fully funded so that our court system is
not put into a shagrin as I call this
say gee we'd like to do it but we can't
and uh and do it meaning appointment of
attorneys or are the costs that it takes
for our for our children so I just off
of that as a as a concept
concept web yeah so so I'm sorry wa a
minute I just wanted to remind you that
it was brought to our attention that we
do the states do have um access to the
federal funding through that title for
the Social Security Act um to help pay
for attorneys for Children and
Families yeah which which again fund
those are things that would need to be
part of the research that's done of how
to get in line for that and to make sure
that the funding from the federal
government uh is allocated for New
Hampshire's
needs and and know for what
proposing well I always use that it's
for the children yes no I understand and
that's but as an aggressive Advocate
with manners I have found dealing with
faceless bureaucrats you better be fully
loaded when you're doing it and that's
with with our uh you know I'm not trying
to be funny there but that's what I've
learned over time is uh is make sure
we're doing that have the right thing so
intellectually we've we've covered our
our bases and we have the right answers
to say here's the here's the reason for
the investment and we want access to
this funding for the betterment of our
all our C all our citizens regardless of
financial
ability when they come to court but yeah
anyway could we long thank you Mr
chairman I I so I'm I'm hoping that the
general court could take a consensus on
all of this stuff whether whether
there's a payment coming forward or not
uh knowing that you know first of all I
I agree uh if this has to go to Finance
Finance is going to say yeah we're all
set uh we got the budget out you know
wait till 25 when we're redoing that
budget but I'm I'm wondering if there's
is a uh consensus that could be taken
from the general court you know a vote
from the general court saying um saying
positively yes um we agree with having
uh
attorneys uh appointed uh a must um at
some
level um without without the implication
of a without the implication of a
financial
note um I I don't know if that's ever
been done um but I mean I I I I learned
a lot today with both presentations both
sides um and um and I lean towards both
sides um and I don't want any of that to
go to waste so so um I I mean I I like
the effective date
scenario uh maybe uh postponing the
financial finding out what the
federal what feds have to offer um so
implement this uh one of
24 and then uh take a couple of other
bites that we may want uh to implement
in 125 uh which be set
up oh I'm sorry 125 and then
126 it would start yeah the initial
would start at 125 right this one here
can you that's what the court system
wants can you do a bill in two parts I
yeah you can't
obligate oh you can't obligate another
future future body you know they have to
be part of that that's that's that's
what I've that's what I've learned thank
you
here okay through through the special
Committee of family uh Court
maybe on Family
Court thank you just a couple things I
mean if you're considering like having
different start effective dates which
would be a really good way of um
avoiding this financial Pitfall that
you're thinking of one thing to keep in
mind is that if you are going to start
with the discretionary appointment of
councel then jrpg would ask that you
also do something that is not very
costly at all which is to make sure that
children's the foster care children's
Bill of Rights is amended to reflect
that discretionary the right to ask for
discretionary appointment of councel so
because we see those two things as going
hand
inand and the the casa Amendment does
not include amending the CH Foster
children's Bill of Rights to inform
children that this is an Avenue they
might decide to
pursue what what's the law the law
number on that so that's the
170g hold on 21 oh okay that's so the
idea right so the idea would be to at
least you know we that's where we notify
children in foster care of they're you
know the pan of all the rights that they
have if if the inclination is to add
this right the right for them to seek
discretionary appointment of council
then they should be so informed in that
booklet that they get with all of their
rights
enumerated please do representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman so if we're not
including the stuff on uh
placement we you still I I the if if
we're just doing the bare minimum and
then the placement stuff we're doing for
kicking out a little bit um the Bill of
Rights would still need to be
because because I don't see the
placement it does it's not tied just a
placement it would say to the children
courts have discretion to appoint
counsel for you you have a right to ask
a court to appoint counsel for you at
any stage of the
proceeding okay and it and it and it
doesn't well and it could be clear to
say that you know that discretion
doesn't mean that the Court's gonna say
yes but okay right but it would at least
be an accurate um representation of this
expansion because it is an expansion
right yeah um and then the other thing
um just to throw out there is that
generally you know in court appointed
councils there Council cases there is a
cap to what attorneys can generally
charge so when we're looking at
approximately 150 cases a year with like
a $2500 cap that's a total of
$325,000 for $ 150 cases so it's not
it's not breaking the bank um just so
that you know and I understand that one
way of dealing with this that and and
but the other part of this is that um
the fore money the federal money which
is there it's not a huge amount you
should just know um it's probably around
I think we figured out it was around
what 12 or
14% of that cost so it's not going to be
a really huge it'll be it'll it can help
but um I just don't want to represent
that as like a huge portion of what the
cost would be it would help to spray the
cost and hopefully having kids out of
residential facilities would free up
some
money Casa uh respectfully request that
you just stick with the the casa
amendment that everybody agrees to part
of the issue with the Bill of Rights
from Casa's perspective as we got into
the adjudicatory hearing issue that you
heard a lot of testimony about so we may
get there and I think we we likely will
but for now uh it's kasa's position that
we should stick with the good uh first
step of of the casa
Amendment and agree to the
commission
yes study
committee
divion one yes no divion one is where
the judicial Council funding
is the judicial Council would be paying
the bills for these cases excuse
me so the study committee I I probably
should have my microphone on would make
sense normally I would say oh I don't
want to kick it out because it would it
would take too long I do think that the
special committee that we've had on the
Family Court has been incredibly
beneficial the amount of time it's taken
would take no longer than if we just put
something in and we had to kick it out
because of Finance anyway so that way it
would give us a clearer cut look at what
we are actually looking at get some real
numbers so that like you said in your
case where we can then push the entire
thing through we don't have a lot of
Hang-Ups here and there so I know that I
think a lot of times when we say oh
there's going to be this special
commission or whatever I know I thought
that like that's so much time but we're
already looking at time anyway because
um you know just to implement this we
certainly don't want to overwhelm a
system and make it you know bad for
people who would normally it would it
flow a little easier anyway so I I think
that would be a I see where that would
be beneficial for sure and I think you
did bring it up last time that maybe
this is so big but this is so big and we
respect everybody's opinion here and I I
always say it's not that we're fighting
different battles we're fighting the
same battle just in a different way so I
think we are are looking at this and I
want to really
be really be thoughtful on that so I
think the commission I that would be my
vote for sure to to do
that oh wait a minute there was
another
yes no no it's Steen well well I'm I say
no let's just clarify where we're where
we are at the moment uh right now is um
addressing the casa Amendment as the uh
as provided to us here to
replace uh the uh the amendment that was
provided in total the original not
Amendment but the the original bill as
provided to us and this being uh
replacing all doesn't say in here it
just says amend one section I should say
one section of it the rest rest of the
bill are remaining the same well no they
intent is to uh their their intent was
to replace the whole bill oh replace the
whole bill okay it doesn't say that on
agreement from everyone that 535 is to
not go that's that I know I did get that
last time that was the one thing
everybody agreed on last time was that
535 is not
workable oh all right yeah I'm I was
looking for it to replace to re replace
it just says amend and to a specific see
I actually read what you provided so I
read all these things all right but that
is that is to um uh replace in total the
the bill uh and with what we have here
that's your
recommendation and now and that being
would notwithstanding comments to come
right now but that would be our
recommendation to the uh the full
committee yeah uh on on the
31st that's the the product of our our
action number one that's our action and
the 1A is the establishment of a study
committee to to uh to be formally uh
appointed immediately and then we meet
meet stop meeting immediately and that's
also over the summer
months uh as well for the
nextd
right
no oh
yeah make the decision
Andis oh excuse me
sir
should we meet one more time on the 25th
or whatever or or or do you think we'
got it I mean I'm I'm I'm looking at
what additional non Financial
consensus I would say I don't think
there
is I mean what I've heard here unless
unless there's an something to add to
this to to an amendment un that's in
that regard yeah yeah picking from the
other Amendment
something that's not as critical or or
not yeah yeah yeah that's I mean I think
a study committee now is is good um
because uh you know we want to be able
to bring something forward uh in the
next uh the next
B yeah yeah the whole point about on the
study is because of the financial issue
and uh and and that's when we have the
full um Mo all the professionals
participant in that so that we don't
something isn't missed and then it
become by missed or overlooked not
missed it just what and but it takes
takes the time to do instead of being
under a rush like like this and and uh
have all entities spoken for represented
and that gives the uh the the weight
when the advocacy takes place before the
respective committees everyone will be
in play and on and on the same page and
not have a conflict uh on interpretation
is it a dog or a cat we got to we got to
make sure we're on the same
page so that so that being said uh oh go
I'm sorry representative B sorry my
concern is
that I go back to working in the best
interest of the children and I'm
concerned about dragging it on because
how many children are going to fall
through the crack or how many children
are going to not have their needs met
because we're delaying putting forward
something that we know that is needed um
and I do agree that we have other bills
that are going through that have a
financial note on them and
um I just think unless we have it down
and we say this is what we need to do
it's not going to get done it won't get
put in the budget either so I think I'm
just
and I would like to just move forward I
guess I'm just saying I'm thinking about
the children and what they need and
pushing it out a year you just have to
wonder how many children are not going
to have their needs met um and be
represented properly
um I would be in favor of pushing it
forward and letting the full committee
make a
decision well off for one thing in that
regard uh the and J looking at the
amendment there from Kasa here it is
stating and
relative uh in representing the
expressed interest of the child as the
states here is that there they the
appointments will take place the
question will become in how many cases
you have is will there be the money to
pay for that attorney attorney to do it
and if it's not there it ain't happening
so it's it's and then we we'll be saying
well we'll hope it happens because if
the funding isn't isn't there it will
not take place you know so um so in
looking here is at the at the lease that
saying when they say may appoint an an
attorney that's going to be be driven by
a uh value judgment based on okay what
who who we hiring and then what's the
cost of that hiring and does it fit
within the current budget that's
available and uh so this is is looking
out after the children and I'm I'm I
joined with Miss ball I said I I'm a
representative ball and that's here I
have the same uh commitment to it
looking after those who need assistance
and doing it doing it now but I I am
what I'm not one is to say passing a
bill and then it doesn't have the tools
to effectually apply the bill in this
case the the cost of the service and uh
so that's what I'm looking here is how
do we get this get this started so that
there's a commitment to a resolution and
not a constant Battle of U where the
funds come at any given
time on on
this representative long thank thank you
Mr chairman yeah I mean I'm feeling like
I'm not doing all I can is the way I'm
feeling um and I I agree that pass the
policy uh and then let Finance know that
this is what we're looking for um you
know I don't know how if I'm on finance
I'll find it but I'm not on fance so
it's your job to find it um I you know
because I I
I you know I I get that scenar I've had
plenty of bills pass where Finance just
says yeah we don't have the money and
we're not we don't the money we do have
we're not going to put towards this and
I had to accept that but at least I gave
them my opinion this is or the state
gave them their opinion this the policy
committee gave gave them their opinion
this is what we need um you know and
there's a couple of uh there's a couple
advantages I think for the uh children
uh with respect to the um appointment of
attorneys um that I I agree is gonna is
g to be give the state of New Hampshire
Better situated uh with with helping
helping giving these kids
opportunities um so yeah so
it could be a discussion in the full
committee I guess because I I'm you
know what what what can we add from from
if I may from uh the from the other
uhg on on that as part of the ca draft
Amendment what
else was yeah um would you recommend I
mean actually I I like the option of the
effective dates um I think that's
helpful uh and and I need to confer with
jrpg to see what
uh what would be no what would be the
what what would be not the major
controversial issues but something that
will allow us to get the general court
to agree uh to to have a stance on some
issues that we want affected um
the
final right because it would
allow it would
allow piece of it to go through the
budet get and
then the bar to build up the attorney
actually would some of those
administrative that you heard about and
and enable this to move forward in a way
that a judge they will be to we think
that there will be a great opportunity
to do that so but again you know there's
study committee My worry is if there's
no statement of policy there's no money
attached who's going to come to a
training to train up to do this work
while we're waiting to see what happens
next year and there's going to
are lot of
attor May
attesting yeah I I personally at the
study committee I you know I sat here
for a couple hours and I'm I went
through a study committee I I know much
more than I've ever uh thought I would
know uh and thank you for that so I I
agree about the study committee I don't
believe it's a study committee needed I
think we I think the general court needs
to set policy and let the finances roll
wherever they're going to roll that you
know it's um not out of you know it's
not in the hands of
CFL
um um
so yeah so so I think there's I think
there's um you know I just want to make
the I just want to make our stance
stronger um you know because I'm I feel
it I'm not 100% in it um you know it's
not a Band-Aid it's substantial but not
as substantial as I think it could
be I mean what what you could consider
is in that like a phase in you have the
discretionary happen you know is I think
it couldn't occur before depending when
it's passed before January of 20 24 is
that correct yes and along with that you
could huh it's 25 oh 25 I'm sorry yeah
okay 20 and then you could have the um
at the same time the change in the
notice to the children and the Foster
children's Bill of Rights and then you
could have the right to counsel now and
and I have to say this is limited
remember we're only limiting the right
to counsel to children in placement in
residential facilities or who are at you
know very imminent risk of that
situation
that you could have kick in like July
1st of 2025 because then you're in the
budget year so then it could be included
in the
budget does that make sense did I get it
wrong yes I got it wrong or yes I got it
right the law so if they pass the law
and the effective date is July 1st
2025 yeah listen to yeah the next next
budget is uh is in 25 the next budget
discussions will begin January of
25 but again no law no funds no right
they're not gonna something that is so
so we could do uh July
26 but we can't tie another legisl
that's
right
jary January
2025 the one hiccup for CA was that we
don't have the resources we don't have
the people that's right there one hiccup
right do we think that we get enough
people have I mean I'm all I think they
will I think Michelle I agree with
Michelle I think I think people will
stop okay put represent then I'm GL to
recommend
it we can have people that's
fine but I think we do need to take into
account with what
um